Hey Thoughty2 here.
You may be surprised but McDonald's is no
longer the world's biggest restaurant chain,
Subway is, with 7,000 more locations worldwide
than McDonald's.
McDonald's have 31,000 restaurants internationally.
McDonald's has more customer's daily than
the entire population of Great Britain, they
serve over 68 million people every day, that's
about 1% of the world's population.
McDonald's serves 75 hamburgers every second
and was one of the few businesses that grew
throughout the recession.
McDonald's $27.5 billion yearly revenue makes
it the 90th-largest economy in the world.
McDonald's has 761,000 employees worldwide,
more than the entire population of Luxembourg.
It is estimated that 1 in every 8 American
workers has been employed by McDonald's.
In fact many celebrities worked at McDonald's
before they became famous, including Rachel
McAdams, Sharon Stone, Shania Twain, Jay Leno,
Pink and James Franco.
McDonald's is the world's largest distributor
of toys, with one included in 20% of all sales.
Between 2011 and 2013 McDonald's plans to
open one restaurant every day in China.
In the continental US you are never more than
107 miles away from a McDonald's.
The farthest spot away from a McDonalds in
the US lies in the grasslands of South Dakota,
between two tiny hamlets, called Meadow and
Glad Valley.
At this spot you are 107 miles or at least
a 2 hour car journey away from a McDonald's.
Americans alone consume an artery-busting,
one billion pounds of beef at McDonald's every
year.
That's 5.5 million cattle.
The ominous McDonald's golden arches are recognised
by more people internationally than the cross.
A survey found that 88% of people could identify
the arches, but only 54% recognised the Christian
cross.
There are 10 countries where you won't find
a single McDonald's.
These are:
North Korea
The Seychelles
Syria
The Vatican City
Cambodia
Zimbabwe
Vietnam
Nepal
Kazakhstan, which is the largest country in
the world to be McDonald's free.
and finally Barbados.
McDonald's sells unique items in every country.
Did you know in Portugal you can order soup
at Mcdonald's and in India where the majority
of the population doesn't eat beef.
McDonald's serve meals such as the Chicken
Maharaja Mac and the Potato-Patty McAloo Tikki
Burger.
In Hong Kong you can order a Red Bean Pie
for dessert.
In France they sell a burger on a stone oven-baked
ciabatta roll.
Pulp Fiction fans will be happy to hear that,
yes you can buy a beer in McDonald's in France,
the Netherlands, Germany and Austria.
And all across Europe you can order a Royal
with Cheese.
McDonald's is the single largest owner of
real estate in the world.
They actually make the majority of their revenue
from the rent payed to them from their franchise
owners.
McDonald's paid rappers to mention Big Macs
in their songs to appeal more to young people.
Hip Hop artists were paid about $5 every time
one of their songs with Big Mac in the lyrics
played in the US.
But where in the world will you pay the most
for a Big Mac?
Norway.
In Norway you'll pay the equivalent of $23
US Dollars for a single McDonald's meal of
a Big Mac, soda and fries.
In Hong Kong McDonald's has wedding packages
on its menu.
Yes you can actually get married at McDonald's.
Hamburgers and chicken nuggets aren't that
profitable, one of the most profitable items
on McDonald's menu is soft drinks.
McDonald's is the world's biggest retailer
of Coca-Cola.
But the Coke sold at McDonald's isn't your
traditional soda.
Most fast food chains buy Coca-Cola syrup
for about 53 pence per litre.
They add the syrup to carbonated water.
A medium Coke that sells for 75 pence only
contains 5 pence worth of syrup.
Buying a large coke for 85 pence costs the
retailer another 2 pence worth of syrup.
And last but least, McDonald's apple pies
are the hottest substance known to man.